training's really important so you can
be prepared for any situation for a
couple of reasons number one you don't
know what other people are going to do
[Music]
[Applause]
so I started doing courses must mean
back about 2007 and that brought home to
me how much I didn't know about riding a
motorcycle he they're managing the
momentum of the bike through the
practice that they've done go to a
course and it just makes you remember
all the things that you're taught in the
first place so the first part of pulling
out and turning left is to put your left
foot on the ground then all of a sudden
your bike's leaning in the direction
that you want to go now
that is the most dull and boring thing
I've ever seen in my life but that's
what good technique is it's actually
uneventful
there's actually five forces you can
undertake through the writers program
there's two for our courses an urban
commuter there's no suggesting a scooter
survival course we've even got three a
hair courses so wrong silver and gold
level so basically basically it is a
course for every level of rider
[Music]
we're just writing down create writing
techniques good habits all the courses
have a strong focus on awareness on
increasing your observational skills now
if you're on the road in 18 19 20 50 K
this is your minimum say following this
[Music]
each year we've seen an improvement and
positive outcomes in the in the right
fervor ACC steps so we can see a direct
correlation between riders being less
likely to be injured if you've taken
part in a rivalry of course
[Applause]
you can teach old dogs new trucks the
worst thing that's gonna happen is
you're gonna have a great day with
friends the best thing that's going to
happen is you're gonna learn some skills
that they're going to keep you alive a
little bit longer
[Music]
[Music]